[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il est bien souvent parfois elles sont
libres
elles font des cerfs-volants j'écrive de
lire parfois elles sont ouverts papa
elles sont courants
honteux il ya des gens qui les fermes et
des gens qui les tente on les met sur le
coeur on les mains dans les poches
elle puise des parcourir les mioches si
elle va servir parfois autour du monde
on peut les unir sa forêt
donne moi ta main
voilà
dauphin
la chaîne
[Musique]
watson
ma
[Musique]
forêt l'onf heureuse pas paraître sont
si seuls 30 sont baladés situent les
prend dans la gueule
il ya des gens qui les gens ya des gens
qui les gants
on m a coupé il ya déjà deux mois
[Musique]
toi
m
deux chaînes
[Musique]
à
oui
[Musique]
notoire
[Applaudissements]